today I'm going to be speaking with Max
Burns who's an award-winning Democratic
strategist and also founder of third
degree strategies Max recently wrote an
article asserting that we may we may
finally be at a Tipping Point when it
comes to gun violence and gun safety in
the United States we're going to talk
about that Max great to have you on I
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me so I mean listen my audience knows
we've heard this so many times before
this we this is definitely a Tipping
Point you know Sandy Hook was a Tipping
Point or Pulse Nightclub or whatever
else the case may be even popular
reforms like a background check as a
requirement for any gun transaction
including Private person-to-person Sales
very popular with the American public
after Sandy Hook can't get it done so I
think people would be right to be
skeptical that we are now at a Tipping
Point so late out for us why now what
has changed
well you're absolutely right I think the
gun violence conversation has been one
that's been littered with
disappointments from the beginning but
what we're seeing now is a really
interesting Confluence of factors one is
that even though Congress is essentially
useless on gun policy right now we're
seeing a real golden age of democratic
lawmakers in States passing legislation
that would have been unimaginable even a
few years ago Gretchen Whitmer for
example uh just passed an 11 Bill gun
reform package that would have ended her
career back in 2008 now they're talking
about her as a potential candidate for
president the other side of this is the
NRA they are in free fall and what was
once the biggest gun rights group in
America can now barely afford to keep
the lights on in its office much less
fund the candidates that have distorted
this conversation for decades so there's
this this unique window of weakness on
the right and strength on the left
that's really create getting a unique
space for a gun conversation that leads
to actual legislation
I think a couple of the difficulties are
and part of this relates to what is or
could be done at the federal level and
what is or could be done at the state
level
a lot of this right now for example when
you talk about the Gretchen Whitmer
package we're talking about the state
level and here there's a sort of like
moral hazard situation where the state's
most willing to deal with this stuff
often are the ones that already are kind
of ahead on the stricter side when it
comes to gun safety as it is so then
when we think about well how do we deal
with this issue in South Carolina or
Texas we start to think federally and
one of the difficulties about federal
gun safety legislation is that running
on it for National candidates often
isn't a great idea from a strategy
perspective which I would be glad to let
you speak to as well but we there's this
idea and maybe it's true maybe it's not
that when you run National campaigns
including for like Senate right because
you you're in DC but your constituents
are in your state that when you talk
about gun safety regulations you rarely
bring new voters to support you but you
often activate people who disagree with
you and so there's that difficulty of
saying well the way to get Texas and
West Virginia and South Carolina to do
something is to go Federal but
campaigning on this stuff federally
often backfires so how do you do that
yeah I think that's a great point and
one of the interesting challenges here
is that for years Democrats were sort of
bought into this Republican message that
it was political suicide to talk about
guns in a campaign right I remember
following the Virginia Tech shooting
Democrats came out the day after to
publicly reassure America that they
wouldn't dream of passing any gun
control legislation uh and now those
same people are leading major campaigns
in States and federally on gun reform
and that's in large part due to the rise
of groups like every town Moms Demand
Action these new groups that have sort
of adopted the rights organizing
approach for this and we see that now
that the majority of Americans have in
some way been touched by gun violence
numbers in support of gun reformer at
record highs and we're seeing that
really start to break down the old
Coalition in Tennessee the Republican
Governor Lee is supporting red flag
legislation in Utah the Republican
Governor alongside every town passed a
bunch of gun reforms that make it
tougher to get a gun and require
background checks that's a coalition
that was unimaginable even a few years
ago that Republicans are seeing the
pressure mount and actually realizing
it's safer to take incremental guns
safety steps this is a completely
different landscape than I think
Republicans are used to playing in and
it's one where Democrats can actually
talk about guns and find that people are
agreeing with them for the first time
since 1994. what is the timeline on
which you think we could see action on
some of these areas
I think it's much quicker than than we
think if we're looking at States the
more that we've organized and this is a
really key part of every town is they
are funding State races they're cheaper
they have a bigger impact on actual
legislation and we're seeing that start
to create a momentum for National change
once red states which are
disproportionately affected by gun
violence have seen that these things
work they're actually pretty excited to
talk about them and that's something
that we're seeing distorted by the gun
lobby but when voters go to the polls
they are voting on this issue it's a big
reason why you see Joe Biden has gone
from saying he won't talk about social
issues at all in 2024 to opening with an
ad that talks heavily about gun violence
Democrats can see it's a winning issue
and they're for once really finding
their voice here
we have in the United States sort of
three separate gun issues you have mass
shootings you have individual homicides
affecting one or two individuals per
incident and then you have suicides
using firearms in thinking about and the
the prescriptions would be different for
these three different categories if we
think about mass shootings for a moment
I've put out a list of 10 or 12
different ideas that would never
eliminate every mass shooting but would
certainly do something to reduce the
number and there are some trends that we
see when it comes to the mass shootings
age of the shooter typically under 25
type of firearm used often an assault
style rifle you know there's these
trends that we start to see what's the
lowest hanging fruit in your mind that
would blend the most effective changes
that could be made with ones that are
most likely to actually be politically
viable
well I think there's this unique moment
here that we see with Tennessee with
Utah with North Dakota that's talking
about raising the age for gun ownership
uh that you combine background checks
which we've seen even in in Michigan was
a hugely popular thing Universal
background check used to be a consensus
Republican position in the Bush
Administration they have gone so far off
on that that it doesn't resemble
anything Americans want but you combine
that background check legislation and
red flag legislation and you have
immediately handled two of the most
vulnerable populations people who are
going to use their guns for violence
against others knowingly at the time
they buy the gun and people who are
going to use it for self-harm
disproportionately young people and in
rural communities in agricultural
communities huge rates of gun suicide
and it all has to do with gun access and
we can talk about making sure guns
aren't in the hands of kids without
talking about these Republican
conspiracies of stealing everyone's guns
away and we're finding that the space
for that conversation is getting bigger
every year when it comes to the next
um what's remaining I guess I would say
of the Biden first term and you know
we'll see if whether there's a second
term in sort of what framing he uses for
for the 2024 campaign given the
circumstances in in the House and Senate
Republicans controlling the house uh
Democrats controlling the Senate at this
point
what's your sense of at the federal
level what might be possible you know I
understand you're saying that Senate
Republican I'm sorry that state
Republicans to some degree uh seem more
willing to take action what about things
that would have to go through the House
and Senate
so that's the really big sticking point
here is that Republicans have already
said that the bipartisan gun bill that
they gave Joe Biden is it for them they
do not want any more so it's going to be
basically a status quo situation until
voters in 2024 can be heard yeah and one
of the reassuring things we're seeing is
that just in the same way that Beltway
Consultants said don't talk about
abortion in 2022 it'll be polarizing but
that turned out to be one of the leading
issues for voters we're seeing the same
thing now with guns and it's one reason
why Joe Biden who is as I'm sure you
would agree very risk-averse is
comfortable opening his re-election
campaign talking about gun violence do
you have any insights and this is
getting very specific now you know
there's something we can look at the gun
safety issue mental health video games
all the stuff that is always thrown
around but there is something intangible
maybe about American Gun culture that
doesn't exist in some of the other
countries with relatively High rates of
gun ownership wherein I don't know it's
just sort of like it's more common in
the US that someone would see Firearms
as a way to solve a personal problem an
interpersonal problem a societal problem
that doesn't seem to be the case in many
other countries
is there anything that can be done to
restructure that relationship between
Americans and guns which seems to be
sort of like a layer that's above all
the policy that could be put in place
there is I mean it's fundamentally a
constitutional issue I'm old enough to
remember when people were blaming video
games for violence but the problem has
always been that guns in this country
often have more rights than the people
they're killing and the fact is they the
position has moved to such a maximalist
one on the right that doesn't reflect
anything even a few years ago that the
Court held uh on guns there's now
essentially Republicans arguing for an
unlimited right to own any gun that you
want and they're saying that anyone even
Republicans who propose Common Sense
limits are against democracy and against
the Constitution and it's polarizing
people to violence because when you're
told your fundamental rights are being
taken by a tyrannical government that
justifies almost anything in order to
protect your rights and we're seeing
that happen I mean we're seeing former
Maga voters in Nevada who shot at
elected officials they thought were
stealing an election question until the
Supreme Court or congress gets some
constitutional momentum to rethink The
Madness of our current interpretation of
the Second Amendment it's tough to get
anything long-term accomplished last
thing I want to ask you about I have
heard from many uh progressives
including friends of mine but also
people who just call into my show who
Express views very similar to mine on
the issue of gun safety and and what
they would like to see but also don't
like the idea of the right Wingers being
the only ones with the guns and so they
have armed themselves particularly in
the last few years they have become
Progressive gun owners gladly willing to
subject themselves to background check
mental health eval liability insurance
all the things we would want to put in
but they don't like the idea of the
right Wingers being the ones who
disproportionately have the guns have
you seen this have you heard it is it a
race to the bottom or neurological
reaction to what we're seeing out in the
world oh I've absolutely Heard It In
fact I believe the fastest growing group
of gun owners is black women and they're
doing this in response to the increasing
racial polarization and race-baiting on
the right and I'll tell you one thing
that is sure to get us into the courts
is the idea of black people owning guns
is not something Republicans consider to
be the Second Amendment we saw that with
philando Castile who was an NRA member
that they did not stand up for at all
the quickest way that we can get to a
meaningful gun reform conversation is
for Republicans to get scared at all of
the non-republicans who are buying guns
but it's I to me a completely rational
response and it's a sign of government
policy failure that people feel the need
to have multiple guns to protect
themselves from their own government's
inability to act to protect them that we
should be ashamed of that
we are going to link to Max's piece
about this issue we've been speaking
with Max Burns who's a democratic
strategist and also founder of third
degree strategies Max really appreciate
your time and insights today
thank you so much